what's up reject nation got aaron back
with me again today we're going to
continue
umbrella academy episode 2 the franco
footage great job
before we go into that guys first off
hit that subscribe button click that
notification bell so you get notified
whether next umbrella academy reaction
is up or if there's another youtube
video we put up that just
interests you full length reaction watch
alongs for umbrella academy season two
will be over at our patreon
page this will be reaction highlights
according to the rules supposedly can
only allow 10 minutes in total of
footage to be shown here on youtube
over at our patreon we cover a lot of
television shows where we have reaction
highlights and watch alongs for
a whole bunch of tv and those shows are
supernatural
doctor who jojo's bizarre adventures the
promised neverland attack on titan death
note my hero academia hunter hunter one
punch man full metal alchemist
brotherhood violet evergarden demon
slayer and there are many other shows
where we just do the watch alongs for
them
as well we got a whole bunch of content
including a weekly q a podcast we love
you guys can go ahead and show your
support over at our patreon page today
anywho let's get into this
[Music]
all right
what the hell i mean some people survive
i never see someone dance i waited this
kind of music
yeah welcome back
what the hell
[Music]
what is your deal dude why does a fish
need to smoke though i've dropped turds
bigger than her
[Laughter]
bars
[Music]
downgraded
oh jesus oh i thought she got
thought you got him oh no mr five
huh oh it's gonna be like where's the
umbrella
this season damn man it's so cold
suspicious mib looking dude what is that
what do you have that number frankel
footage frankel footage that's the name
of the
episode oh you sneaky son of a [ __ ]
have you seen that check vanya's vagina
that's how they get it goin
bars bars
i gotta say his hair looks good he's
rocking it all things considered
at least his hair looks good
[Laughter]
a day before car alarms oh snap
slow mo luther oh
vanya say something vanya say something
smash that car up jump after her
[Laughter]
i've never seen a more sinister milkman
in my life if you're the milkman
in one of the milkman costumes shouldn't
you be the one driving instead of the
two guys that are dressed up
that would bring the least amount of
attention
oh no whoa that's racist
[Music]
come
their eyes get all [ __ ] up now didn't
happen season one see no of her powers
i don't think so all she said was i
heard a rumor but she didn't say what
the rumor was
yeah but she chose not to and i took it
as the husband was like saying no no
don't do it
okay i like the addition of this guy
yeah it's cool
he's cool so far franco footage cousins
[Laughter]
you're way too into this
[Laughter]
excuse me
why because pogo and grace aren't in the
seasons
some cast members
she has plot armor she needs to come
no i am his wife
oh man what about your daughter
it's a good thing these problems do not
exist today oh yeah
jesus is he is he like some kind of
religious leader
things like is he a cult
a guru or something
actually the line is he lies
the governor
that's such a normal
[Laughter]
whatever's in the frankel footage
i love the way the show was shot yeah
it's shot so beautifully whatever he
wanted us to see
it's on this fight
uh-oh what the hell an umbrella i see an
umbrella
please be their dad what is their dad
it's their [ __ ] dad
daddy
wait is he he's like responsible for it
and that's what i took it as i i think
so yeah
you son of a [ __ ]
he's
actually love the complexity of him and
him having a gun
right like you don't need that he
doesn't but worse comes to worse he
might just
have to get her from a distance you know
who i am
oh she's legit
how do we know each other oh this is so
good
[ __ ] no no i'm not i'm not lying did
i do something
[Music]
um
fascinating interesting commit suicide
i thought it was my job to keep everyone
safe
i just made it all worse take your hand
out your pocket bro
so if you're bullshitting me vanya if
you're hiding out here and don't want to
be found i understand
i just came here to tell you but i'm
sorry
for my party
his reaction shoots the kid
what a great backup
about
oh where's that old lady's body
oh seems like
he's into it so they're bored
[Laughter]
[Music]
five points try me
oh those are the people that this oh
they are okay so they are part of the
bureau
the swedes swedes it's just like as
cliche as it gets
damn oh let's go for gravonia but what
are they doing are they protecting oh
they're gonna ignite her powers aren't
they
oh oh
nothing like fresh head for dinner
that's a very 60s
trying to tell freezer we have to stop
that from killing the president
[Laughter]
that kind of wacky [ __ ] this is great
ds umbrella why did you say
i heard a rumor last night so he doesn't
know
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
[Laughter]
i don't remember he forgot what i said
i had a rumor you wanted to mind your
own damn mess
i heard a rumor that you forgot that you
heard me say that i heard a rumor
get that all the oh of the prophet
what did you do klaus this is awesome
you became a freaking guru
this is great and little men around here
who apologize
to women so whatever he did
that must make him a terrible human
being
no one touched me like this since
peabody this canvas is on your
fingertips
it's gonna happen in it oh
mother's touch oh totally missed a
diddle joke with the
i was i was just thinking as you said
that damn i was like ah
she knows how to fiddle where are you
going where are you going amnesia
just jacked her car he's carjacking in
these streets
not my woman this is so interesting
because you've never actually seen the
dad interact with them as adults before
yeah what the hell oh a mystery is a
foot
daddy what the hell oh just disappears
into the smoke
it's almost as if he knows they're there
how'd you get up there
[Laughter]
oh there's someone else in here
[Music]
oh it's gonna be baby pogo baby pog low
pogo
where you got a little pogo
[Music]
can you talk yet oh
pogo we totally call that [ __ ] you're so
cute you're so cute little poker
oh [ __ ] oh no oh
oh no pogo
oh god oh your dad's gonna be ass ain't
he
oh oh damn oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
do you what the hell
oh damn what an unexpected twist
oh crap daddy can fight whoa
damn son
you lured him out that's great that's so
smart you clever [ __ ]
oh nice
oh no diego
you how do you not know it was your dad
wait what did he say i don't know oh
what are you saying what did you
everybody say
what a mind [ __ ] wow
hell yeah dude
that's a fresh take that was awesome oh
yeah oh wow
dude that was awesome that was awesome
that was great we gotta put that part
back to make out what they said but oh
let's talk about it yes
damn that was a great [ __ ] episode
that was a great episode man just like
classic netflix you know just
raises the stakes gets better every time
you know they always manage to subvert
expectations
or you know give you what you're kind of
expecting but do it in a different way
yeah when i was editing back the last
reaction i was like oh we both mentioned
it two different times like will we see
reginald hard grapes in in this season
of course they set it up
like yeah in the second half you're
gonna see most shows might do something
of like they show up he's like a young
amateur professor who people think is
crazy
and then they meet him and you're like
who are you right
you gotta convince them to do this in a
completely different unexpected way
where
like oh this guy is like a nighttime
martial arts expert maybe vigilante he's
a badass it reminded me of um
kind of like uh what's his name uh green
hornet a little bit of a
little bit of like yeah those ones that
harken back a little for a green hornet
the spirit
yeah the spirit even like a bit of a
dark man angle it was kind of
what are those kind of hats called you
know the fedoras fedoras yeah
fedora hat wearing crime fighting mother
efforts right
we went back in between shooting and
found that line uh he says amateur to
diego
and it's like the perfect one word
to say to be like oh he's it's the most
hargraves thing
he could possibly say the most thing is
it's the thing he would say to his kids
and it's still such a good mysterious
point where you're like
there could be a version of this where
graves does know who diego is
right you know he's rewatched the season
recently and he stayed young for a
really long time because
they they showed at the beginning like
he was on some kind of place where
there were spaceships and released some
kind of yellow essence and we don't know
if he's like an alien or something which
is why he's
he looks so young at this point in the
60s yeah man i think it makes sense that
as somebody who
trained people to be superheroes he
would know how to fight himself this is
like the origins of
he's he's always had this embedded in
his head of wanting to create some type
of
heroic team i mean like the fact that he
has all these martial arts skills
he's uh developing pogo right
at this which is great i love that we
got to see him i was like yes finally we
get to know like the origins of pogo i
wanted to see the origins of pogo
five right right hits him in the face
and you're like okay he's just he's
still just a chimp it's a little baby
chimp
hasn't developed much and then when he
comes he just claps
yeah you're like oh no he's just a
primate oh god later on reginald just
goes like that he
he jumps off the roof and starts holding
his hand like oh no he's a little
trained he's just very loyal to reginald
so i love him i love this stage i love
diego and five teaming up together
so early on in the show some real heart
moving
endearing moments that uh catch me off
guard as well everything with luther i'm
finding very compelling
luther seems very different this season
like i feel like the actor has been
given a lot more
more range and different something to
play with yeah because yeah just
just the way he speaks his attitude
towards it seems very different from
luther season one which i'm really
i'm really digging the the new direction
they're taking him i prefer it
and i think it's a very natural
direction because as much as the
characters have shifted so much in their
personalities and a lot in their
appearances as well
it seems like a very natural way for
them to develop based off of
all their emotional and physical
experiences they went through in season
one
right like with luther that whole first
season he's essentially wants to be the
captain america you know yeah
could he do shoes could he do shoes
daddy's favorite boy loyal the daddy was
always in denial about
everything and then he just kept having
everything be slowly unraveled until
bombshells were just thrown on his plate
in the last few episodes of season one
he was really late to the game of
realizing my whole life is a lie and
i've been manipulated this entire time
and he's always tried to do the right
thing but it
seemed like he was just making the wrong
choices along the way it's an
interesting complexity because he has to
be on guard if he has to save the world
again or save the day he'll have to take
out vanya
but really he he also wants to apologize
because there's there's some
it's not a black and white thing like no
vania is the villain or
i just feel bad it's both he has to be
on guard and i like
yeah i like the misdirection that that
scene kind of took you through because
it made you seem like oh he's here to
kill her because of all the bad things
he did but really that moment was to
illustrate
oh i really messed up i was the reason
that she became this way and
that scene between them was
talk that through and kind of confessing
his guilt about what he had done to her
throughout her life
i think it's some great emotional
character work that they're doing
thousand percent what do you think about
the
relationship with [ __ ] and bonya i
think it's growing i think it's gonna
turn into some beautiful baby
i can't wait to see what they do here
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna get the chance to see
vodka explore her
sexuality you know in this new identity
of
60s world that she's now living in and
endure
and doing this during a time where you
know
yeah because 60s were 60s were a big
time of transitioning
from very traditional conservative to
experimental hippies you know right
right drugs mindset yeah
and but homosexuality you know that
culture
still has its struggles today especially
back then very frowned upon
cheating wife there's already so much
context of why there would be so much
resistance on this end i do find it very
endearing right now i do find it very
sweet there's something about the
writing of it currently
i'm not sure what it is that's kind of
missing for me there that
that doesn't it doesn't feel entirely
unique
it's like yeah you're you just seem to
be like [ __ ] is just so
she's a good actress she's great and i
feel like there's more to come i didn't
do any reactions for season one but that
was happening a lot with me i would have
criticisms then i'd let the show play
out
mm-hmm i'd be like never mind
that's how it constantly was even right
down to vanya actually in season one i
was like why didn't you mean ellen page
in this show right
you know like what purpose yeah i was
like oh man
because i would forget she's in the show
and then you're like oh she's like the
most important character yeah yeah yeah
is everybody just like [ __ ] on her
all the
i'm excited y'all time this i kept
feeling like god it's just not
clicking for me and then there's i feel
like there's something going to be with
[ __ ] that's going to have more heft
because right now it's just like yeah
she just says all the right empowering
encouraging things
she's like the perfect pseudo she's like
perfect right yeah
like okay yeah i get it you got a shitty
marriage but you are just perfect when
interacting with vania
yes man i'm really like very
understanding on every account
yeah yeah i'm really scared for her and
then for um
raymond raymond i really i'm really
nervous for their companions because you
know the show's about the family
and uh yeah they're not the family so
i'm sure i think they're gonna well
there's an act there's a lot of com i'm
i'm worried raymond's gonna die the show
seems like it's going there
yeah and plus they got to get out of the
60s they got to get back to their their
time and they can't perhaps
keep that and then eventually luther is
going to see vanya again which will
create a whole new layer of complexity
then raymond's going to flip a switch
like that's why you've been looking at
the moon this whole time
[Laughter]
instantly unlikeable and kill them 30
seconds later
i think the the way they're tying
everything together
of these multiple storylines because you
set it up where
the first episode of season one they all
just come together right that's the
whole thing they've gotten dis and they
come together and then here they're all
coming together little by little by
interesting threats
it's very cleverly woven yeah in a way
that doesn't feel like
convenient you know with the cell you
know klaus gets arrested in the last
episode
aren't they all technically within the
same town they should be they all landed
in the same space seems like klaus was
the one who like ventured off and did
his own thing and became a guru which is
something to uncover later on no a
package to unrap yeah yeah he goes to
jail and then when he's in jail he meets
raymond a few minutes
if if klaus was just there for a few
minutes longer he would have bumped it
upon you i'm surprised
i mean maybe they'll do something where
we'll find out later on
uh allison allison sorry yeah there's a
lot of names guys a lot of names a lot
of characters
maybe they'll do something later on
i wonder how long it was i find it kind
of like weird how none of them have
bumped into each other yeah
they've all been there yeah i wonder how
long it's going to take this show to
actually bring them together
like i wonder if that's going to be like
the next episode episode four or five i
feel like it's coming around the corner
yeah i feel like they're i feel like
what netflix isn't trying to waste time
they're like we're gonna we're gonna
do this you're gonna see them as the
team that the first episode kind of
teased
before they got you know the one thing
that immediately i find kind of weird
about with these last couple episodes is
i'm really wrapped up in the mysterious
plot of what's going on with the jfk
thing
right that's where my mind is and i feel
less concerned about the apocalypse
whereas the first season was very much
like there's an apocalypse coming
five days world's gonna end five days
world's gonna end yeah
they made you so aware of that yeah and
they have made you so aware of that here
especially with like the first 10
minutes of the last episode but i feel
like the focus is feeling a little bit
more grounded
i feel like the end of the world stakes
will come back around obviously i mean
it's still big but it's not
as big as like doom and pending world
which is still on the horizon because
yeah you got the franco footage
which i'm which i'm like i don't know
what the hell's going on there but um
we got some cool mysteries to uncover
got daddy hard grave in there daddy
hargrave uh i'm i'm i'm
curious about the lilac character i like
overall mm-hmm i'm not not in love with
i'm not in love with her
i'm i'm more i'm just waiting to see you
here oh yeah
i'm waiting to see if like she grows
they're making her a three-dimensional
character
but i'm not finding myself really
attached to her to any degree
and i'm waiting to see if did they say
she had visions
or something that's what i was kind of
confused on if they were if they were
hinting that she actually has some kind
of powers
yeah because i know that the 80 or the
40 babies at once happened in the 80s
but maybe there's some kind of incident
in the 60s or like in the not the 60s
but like what yeah
the 40s at this point that could have
happened previously and
she could be one of the people with
power exactly which would be really
interesting
um i feel like she'll warm up show like
this i don't think you
sometimes you don't love it like you're
not in love with her attached right away
but
she might be a character who we do and
then of course lasting swedes the swedes
they're officially part of the bureau
they are part of the bureau
which of course is
looking sassy as ever getting demoted by
her her
fish man chain smoking boss the one
little i mean that is such a weird
design because i love it but i'm like
what is the practicality of all this
fish
why is he smoking it's like a lung
addiction can't so he still keeps
smoking
my question is is this a fish who
developed a man's body or just a man's
body who got
the yeah the whole aesthetic choice i
love
i'm so lost on like the purpose of it
and the design of it
even though i don't think the the
handler in her worlds within the 60s
the sci-fi design of the fish with the
suit is very sexy yes i love the look of
it and i love the whole idea and
personality of it somebody tells me the
handler will play
a helping hand i see what you did there
in uh helping to save the day so helping
save the day i did not
see what you did i don't think she's
gonna i i feel like she might want to
climb her way back up at first
makes sense but i think there's going to
be a lot of resentment
towards how she's been wronged and she's
going to betray them
she's going to pull the general hux
that's the reference for
everything now right that's what
everyone goes to pucks pucks
what the hugs i never remember though
what are you oh yeah yeah
everyone's like yeah right away no one
ever has to think about that
right all right guys well what did you
think of this episode make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell check us on patreon for the full
length watcher longs and also all the
other tv shows we got covered last but
not least let's do up
today is eric horstmann's birthday the
man with the real rejects tattoo
i love you man uh just opened this today
he sent olivia and i gift we had a
squirrel a couple months ago this
uh squirrel passed away ricky and he
sent me this blanket
and i'm really grateful for it so thank
you eric literally after we were done
recording
opening that let me know like tear it up
a little bit we're hugging each other so
you're sweet guy
i'm very grateful for you and you've
affected my life in many
many many positive ways and one day we
will go to atlanta
buy you a beer watch you get drunk we'll
buy you
several shots you know a bottle then a
beer
embarrass yourself defecate yes
i guess banned from atlanta yeah
can't wait for that day man it's a party
per tradition happy birthday
to you happy birthday
to you happy
[Applause]
[Music]
love you buddy be well
you